Tag 3 auf unserem neuen Bauernhof und
ich kann es nicht lassen im haustürmen
sich zwar die Umzugskartons aber ich
will raus in den Garten ich habe so
viele tolle Ideen für diese Gartenhütte
hier aber bevor ich damit loslegen kann
heißt es erstmal entrümpeln und sauber
machen zwischendurch habe ich mir dann
schon mal erlaubt mich in den Garten zu
setzen und ein bisschen zu träumen die
vorherigen Besitzer haben super viele
tolle gartensachen da gelassen das
Problem ist nur dass ich aus meinem
alten Garten ja auch super viel Zeug
habe deswegen musste ich einige schwere
Entscheidungen treffen ich werde aber
versuchen alles was noch irgendwie zu
gebrauchen ist auf eBay Kleinanzeigen an
andere Leute weiterzugeben Töpfe Räumen
habe ich eine spinnenfamilie mit ganz
vielen babyspinnen entdeckt und dann
schnell wieder zurückgestellt über mich
schließlich nicht stören was würdet ihr
aus diesem Garten Schuppen machen ich
brauche auf jeden Fall viel Stauraum für
meine ganzen Gartengeräte ich möchte
eine kleine anzuchtstation haben für
meine Jungpflanzen im hinteren Teil
werden unsere Hühner einziehen aber es
wäre auch schön wenn es irgendwie ein
bisschen gemütlich würde oder